بعد المنتخب الارجنتيني على كرواتيا وتاهل
لنهائي كاس العالم وبعد اقل من اربع ساعات
بس انطلق المواجهه اللي راح تحدد المنافسه
الثانيه على اللقب بين منتخبي المغرب
وفرنسا واذا بتتفرجوا على الاعاده في
المباراه في الغالب خلصت وعرفت النتيجه
كاس العالم خلاص بيخلص والاحد هتنلعب
المباراه النهائيه لكنه حقيقه يعني يشغل
العالم وكان حديث كل الجلسات خلال الشهر
الماضي ومن النشاط التواصل طبعا ما كانت
استثناء ابدا لكن الملاحظه بقوه في هذا
المونديال انه حمى كاس العالم اصاب تويتر
او اصابت عفوا تيك توك بعنف وقوه اكثر من
غير من المنصات وفيها هاشتاجات معينه شفنا
عليها مشاركه مليليه ومن مثلا مقاطع
المباريات لردات فعل لنكت لتعليق لتحليل
المحتوى تنوع صراحه لكن بقي كاس العالم
الموضوع الاسخر على التيك توك الشهر
الماضي